now cnn now cnn's on the defensive line
the best to see them struggle through
the cuomo now they know how it is
three sexual assault charges yeah cuomo
yeah
in new york so he's like trying to like
battle that
it's such a beast he's like i'm old
that's
my grandpa used to greet me like that
you're like all right man
all right my grandma used to greet
that's what he said
he's like my grandfather used to grab my
face like that
hey you know it's funny you say that in
the whole room everyone's like what
yeah yeah some things you shouldn't know
what though in his defense
there there is some truth to that your
grandma used to grab you there is some
truth to how we used to be he's a talent
in the same way that we used to be more
you know casually racist we used to be
more what i'm saying is like stop the
f-word
yeah we used to like gaze you know like
it was very casual yeah man it's a
different time
different era you know like even my oh
man my
we my mom like you look at your parents
your parents have very
racist ideas oh my god my grandmother is
so racist you know
my mom would say some [ __ ] like okay
well my mom was with when the dementia
wasn't
you know one of my closest closest
friends is gay
all right okay he's a brother to me you
know and uh
he was he was sick and i said to my mom
i said yeah yeah he's not feeling well
my mom goes hoo i hope it's not aids
listen i won't be on camera just
[Applause]
so you know it's like you know it's like
so i'm not
i'm not saying it's okay but the thing
is bliss to the like back then like they
didn't know
it's like it always grew back to bill
burr's bit the donald sterling
is it was that was that thing yeah yeah
he goes he's like what did you expect
old billionaires
yeah i don't want you hanging out with
these guys with giant dance all the time
yeah okay it's a real weird thing but so
now
again you know the sensitivity or the
things are being weaponized to get you
know you know you know just we just have
to try to weather the storm
i wish it wasn't so you got to tiptoe it
was it wasn't so
politicized and stuff like that but you
know social media heightens everything
too
again not defending cuomo in any way but
but but i i understand you know what i
mean like i'm what i'm saying is like
you go okay well what's happening here
so he did what to you you know like like
what i don't like is the association
that it's all it's all catch-all
so you know some guy from an old era you
know that sees you and he just goes ah
i gotta yell you pinches your cheek or
whatever whatever the thing or however
the hello is if you're trying to say
that's the same as he put
um drugs in your drink and then you woke
up naked next to him yeah different
are you is there no is there no
distinction between
what you know like so sexual assault is
now the catch-all for everything
yeah catch on for everything and you can
take a blanket
different man then it's like it's like
if you believe that then i go okay
you know because like there's look
listen get messing with people's
boundaries and in their state their
space
you know you you don't know but what i'm
saying is
give somebody the opportunity what we
mean what we need to do move
moving forward is like we have to make
it okay for people to say like
like you got to go hey can i hug you i'm
a hugger you know
that's what i do now yeah you know i'm a
hugger you know okay
you know because maybe somebody's not a
hugger and you might hug somebody
squeezing
tight they might feel uncomfortable i
didn't like what he did yeah yeah you
know and then they go to hr
you know [ __ ] but what i'm saying is do
we have to assume
everyone's a creep can it be like you
know i didn't really feel comfortable
with that
can i get the opportunity to go like oh
man my bad well i was listening to
breakfast club and
they were talking about like the works
because they were saying you know cuomo
in the workspace and
they worked for him and they're not
allowed to do that
so they're having discussion on all
three of them envy
uh charlemagne angel ye they're like
there should be no
flirting in the workspace in my head i'm
like that
that's not right you're assuming all
those guys
are creeps and you're assuming all the
girls
don't want to be hit on well also most a
lot of relationships start in the
workplace i was just about to say
yeah geraldo said that he was like you
know talking about news people that have
gotten together people that work
together
like at what point you know so you i get
it so
because of this you have to have a
catch-all so so because of a few creeps
you have to go okay so none of this
should happen at work and i totally get
that though
like there is a part of it that you go
like you're on a movie set
you know and maybe you and the makeup
lady are vibing
okay i'm with you all right but during
the shooting
it's probably best that you keep it
professional
for sure okay on that rap day oh that's
when you like
listen you free on saturday yeah okay
okay i've been you know so what i'm
saying
is it's more nuanced than just being
like
hey none of this ever you know that's
also not realistic
it's not realistic but because what but
the problem is it's like
unfortunately the few creeps that take
[ __ ] too far ruined it
uh ruined it and even even ourselves we
can look at ourselves
every man i'm i don't care you could
pretend like you're not whatever you
want everybody can lie to themselves
every dude if you look at it on paper
has crossed the line okay interesting
like hey because it depends on
the circumstances and the situation and
the person you're talking to one line
that might work on
one chick it's completely inappropriate
to another
one yeah it also depends on
like unfortunately the difference
between um
annoyance and harassment and
acceptance it's a final is attraction
yeah
yeah you know so it just
you know you know you know so but so you
as a guy i just think that we need to
find
we need to try to act more appropriately
more professional more professional in
professional settings i don't think
there's anything wrong with that
you know it's like it's because then you
know you know because that's because
everybody drops to extremes
so when we're trying to say like i think
it should be okay to date somebody that
you work with
the the extreme people will be like yo
so you think you could grab her ass at
work and
and say you're reading no [ __ ]
yeah i'm not saying that no [ __ ]
yeah they stop putting words in my mouth
and i don't mean it the way people you
didn't stop calling people [ __ ] i
don't you know but it's like you just
say [ __ ] yeah that's
just that's kevin hart's at different
levels you know so i just think that
when you so how did you do that so it is
case by case
look when i probably even said this on
this podcast already but
i remember we had this um for a dying up
here
you know because then it was like me too
error was heavy all right so they had
they would always have a lawyer come in
a consultant before the you start
shooting
and they sit everybody down and they
talk about sexual harassment on the job
but one of the things the lady said it
was like listen
this is not something that you can
necessarily like put on paper
but you know it when you see it all
right
okay it's just like pornography you know
it's like if you have some art book
with like you know it's like statues of
babies and there's like baby booties and
stuff like that
someone easy could be like oh my god
what is this child pornography but you
look at it and you would be like no no
this is art it's clearly art
but like who defines that yeah so like
you like you know when you see it and
harassment is the same kind of thing
all i said to her was hello yeah but did
you go
hello yeah look at this
[ __ ] look at that look at that
straight hr right there i see that left
so i mean there is a way of like you
know you know
you know it's like no okay it's like i
remember i was at this i was at this
restaurant uh
um what is that place uh crap jones on
third
third hell yeah okay do you know jones
all right so you know when jones you
sitting at tables like this
uh-huh and then there's like people
could be right here so
behind me two girls sitting here right
me and my buddy we're just talking
a dude comes over and starts flirting
with these girls
okay yeah he don't know him and it just
it just doesn't go well okay yeah
all right but my thing is like i'm
sitting like this and the girl's sitting
like this so we're literally like this
close to each other okay when the guy
leaves let me
go that didn't go well huh and she was
like oh my god that sure did it
and we started yapping all right she
she's one of these hippie chicks she's
hippie she's got a tank top on dirty air
force
you know what i mean in the middle of
the conference in the middle of the
conversation
her titty pops up
dude
b i don't tell her the titties out but
then she looks down and sees the titties
out
and knows i've been looking at this
titty the whole time
was it a big-ass city it was it normally
says
you
but i made the choice i need to tell her
about this titty yeah she need to know
about just titties
but how i tell her about the titty
is where the harassment comes guys make
a joke
because i can't be like this
yo titty out
later i could say what i was telling her
her
her breast was out and i needed you know
no so i just went
um excuse me
but by the way she knew that titty was
out come on y'all
all right but anyway the point is the
point is i felt like
batman i would i knew in that situation
i said i'm not even listening to her
because she's a mom
because i'm thinking titty and i need to
i need to let her know
yeah you know what i mean i'm just like
looking at her like this
while i get this titty into the
conversation without being a creep
yeah and you know and so what i'm saying
is like it's one of these things that i
say
you know it when you see it you you can
feel it you know when a dude is like
it's like after shows man and you got
these chicks and and and
with their boyfriends and you know and
the chick's a little drunk and she's
like
i like him yeah and then you know you
gotta look at the boyfriend like
oh my gosh yeah yeah awkward [ __ ] yeah
you know cause i'm like [ __ ] tonight
i'm just kidding just kidding rachel
that's my fiance
the music
so but what i'm saying is like you
sometimes you have you had these moments
okay so you know you just gotta go like
hey
how do you deal with it and then you
know you know you have other situations
where the couple looks like the guy's
like
yeah she like you brendan she always
been watching she's been watching you
for a long time
meaning like he wants you to [ __ ] his
girl and you want to sit in the chair
and come on
back up okay so what i'm saying is like
you know how you handle that you just
like uh i mean
you know you know what i mean like how
far is the chair from the bed you know
you're in that sweet yeah
i mean again you know interactions
between human beings
are way more complex and nuanced which
is my favorite i use it all the time
it's way more it's way more than just a
headline on twitter
you know it's way more than that because
people still take your words they'll
parse them and make them
always no matter what what they want but
i say to you okay so
so even if you're doing it like that
then you can
see how there's all different types of
perceptions
you know what i've been saying on my
podcast look i don't mind that people
are sensitive
all right i'm sensitive i'm a sensitive
guy me too that's why when
something happens and somebody says
something about me i get sensitive
so i'm no longer being like oh this
generation is sensitive no they
i don't mind you being sensitive but
what i mind is is when you weaponize it
how about that when i get off stage at
the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this from a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song